[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you.
Thank you everyone from
coming out on a rainy day.
I'm glad you're
here because this
is an incredible opportunity
for me to be sharing some
of my experience over
the past few years,
and also some
ideas that I really
want to discuss with you
after the presentation.
Thank you, Mary, for the
wonderful introduction.
I'm afraid you probably
raised the bar a bit too high.
So I really hope
that I can somehow
meet what people are
expecting after what you said.
I'm going to take you--
it's strange for me working
with Doctors Without Borders
to be talking about Europe.
I mean you know the organization
from working elsewhere
around the world.
And it's a bit bizarre.
How do a bunch of doctors
end up rescuing refugees
in the Mediterranean Sea?
So I'm going to tell you
this story, not because
of the rescue, not
because of what we did,
but because I'm interested
in drawing some conclusions
and thinking together about
how did that come about,
how did it start, how
it is coming to an end,
and what's happening
in the background
politically in
Europe and elsewhere.
So I'll take you through
a couple of slides.
I'll try to make it fast.
Don't worry, it's not a lecture.
Stay.
It's a conversation.
This what was worrying us.
Governments don't take figures.
There's no official figures for
deaths in the Mediterranean.
But the International
Organization for Migration
has been collecting reports
of people's death at sea.
These figures are sketchy.
There are many deaths
that go unreported.
There are many people
that go unaccounted for.
So nevertheless, it's
pretty well documented
that at least 35,000
people have died
trying to cross the
Mediterranean Sea
since the turn of the century.
That's a pretty high number.
If you could draw a geography
of deaths and suffering caused
by borders around
the world, that
would be the absolute center.
So that's what was
worrying us when we
thought about this operation.
These images became
sadly familiar.
Small numbers of deaths
every week, every month
became acceptable.
Things were going
on over the years,
and we kept seeing it
on TV, but there was not
much visibility beyond that.
There was not much outrage.
So why does this happen?
Why are these people on
these boats to begin with?
I mean, wouldn't it be
safer to get on a plane?
If you want to go for
North Africa to Europe,
why don't you get on a plane?
It's cheaper.
It's faster.
It's safer.
Why would you risk your
life and your family's life
on an overcrowded boat?
And the reason is because,
for certain kinds of people--
and this is central
to the message--
certain kinds of people
that is not possible.
It's not that European
borders are closed.
Many of you have been
in Europe recently.
Right?
I have been living
in Europe for--
I'm not from Europe.
I've been living in Europe
for a number of years.
European borders are not closed.
They are closed for
certain types of people.
And that's an important thing.
Mediterranean.
Border controls passports have
existed since the 19th century.
They have evolved
over time in Europe
they are not a new thing.
But what has happened over the
last 10, 15 years in Europe--
there's a new graph here.
This is the growth of European
expenditure on defense.
This is Frontex.
This is the agency for
border control in Europe.
Every year, no matter what
the crisis, what budget cuts
have to be made elsewhere,
the border defense industry
is thriving.
Every year there is more
money poured into it.
For next year, it's planned to
be tripled to 33 billion euros.
And it's projected that by
2027, the number of staff
that work in Frontex
is going to be
multiplied by a factor of 10.
It's clear what
priorities are, right?
So these results on a red line
on the map, which obviously
doesn't look like a red line.
How does the border
control happen?
They are not
physical necessarily.
There are border fences.
There are walls.
But this is not the main
tool to keep people out.
The main tools are
administrative and legal
obstacles that are put there.
It's difficult to get visas.
They are carrying
sanctions on airlines
to make sure that they check
that certain people don't
get on planes.
So what causes differential
mobility at the border?
What happens here is movement
is simply an unequal thing.
I mean their right to
move across borders
is not for everyone.
And this is especially aimed--
and I'm using the word aim--
I could say this
disproportionately
affects people from
Africa, the Middle East.
I think these measures are aimed
at certain groups of people.
So how did we get into this?
2011 there was a very well
organized-- over the years
Europe has been spending
money in partnerships
with what they call countries
in the periphery to make sure
that those countries do the job
of stopping people before they
actually get on boats.
This was happening with Libya.
The Berlusconi administration
spent a lot of money
and a lot of diplomacy
to make this happen.
Now what happens when you
get Gaddafi out of Libya?
There was NATO led
intervention in Libya
that was supported by
European countries,
but resulted in an
unintended effect.
The war that was put there,
the incarceration of people,
and then interception of
boats stopped happening.
There was a breakdown of
state control in Libya.
The country got divided.
There were warring
factions vying for control.
So basically the people that
those routes existed forever.
But you had a perfect storm.
You had nobody at the gate.
By 2011, you had famine
in the horn of Africa.
You had war in South Sudan.
You had war in south of Somalia.
You had war in Congo.
You had conflict in northeast
Nigeria with Boko Haram.
You had a number of
issues going on there,
and nobody watching the door.
So that little cross there
slowly but surely became
the epicenter of
migrant drownings.
That's when we really started--
that's what you mentioned.
This was the first that we
said can we really do something
there?
No.
We said no.
I mean, we discussed, and we
were really struggling with it.
This was what we were thinking.
There are push factors that are
really forcing people to move.
There are closed borders.
There's a booming smuggling
business growing in Libya.
We have people preying
on people's desperation
to put them on
boats, charge them
a horrendous amount
of money, and then
put them on the same
boats and push them north.
And of course, people are dying.
That was our analysis, and we
said can we actually do that?
Can we rescue people?
And it took us a long time to
actually venture in to do it.
It was not such
an easy decision.
But I'll tell you about that.
What was happening while
people were drowning?
And this is the
background of this story.
I'm talking about two Europes.
There are many Europes.
When you say Europe, there are
many countries inside Europe.
There are in every country
different political positions,
political parties.
So there are
millions of Europes.
It's a generalization
to talk about Europe.
But for this talk, I want
to talk about two Europes.
There's one Europe of
solidarity, empathy,
refugees welcome Europe.
And there's the
other Europe of what
are these people doing here?
Refugees go home.
Why are they coming?
We cannot take care of everyone.
Why are we rescuing them?
Why are we actually
putting resources
and getting people out of the
sea and bringing them here?
And those two Europes will
be throughout this story
that I'm going to tell you.
Because those two
forces have influenced
decision-making--
political decision-making
that actually has influenced
thousands of people's lives.
So shall we rescue them or not?
Shall we help them or
not was the dilemma.
And that's Lampedusa 2013.
Those Italians in the
audience remember that.
Right?
A boat-- it was
the largest number
of deaths in a single incident.
It turns out that there
was a distress call.
It turns out that
the Maltese Coast
Guard says no, it's the Italians
who have to rescue them.
They tell us, no.
It's the Maltese.
So who should do it?
Finger-pointing.
In the meantime,
360 people drowned.
So there was outrage
across Europe.
Every single European leader
was saying this needs to stop.
They all came up
with a statement
saying why are people
drowning in the 21st century
at our doorstep?
Why is this happening?
When I say European
leaders, even the Pope
came up with a statement.
And the Pope in Italy,
it's an important thing.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's put it that way.
So what does Italy do?
Italy 10 days later,
they deployed the Navy.
They deployed the
Coast Guard closer
to the Libyan shores,
Operation Mare Nostrum.
We need to save people's lives.
This is unacceptable.
They put a lot of resources
into that for an entire year.
They rescued over 100,000 people
and brought them to Sicily.
Of course, that
couldn't last very long.
It very quickly
came under scrutiny.
It very quickly came
under criticism.
It was considered a pull factor.
If we rescue people,
more will come.
That was the logic.
Why are we exacerbating
the problem
by saving people's lives?
The counter argument to
that is, OK, let them drown
and maybe they don't come.
But it was under criticism.
Italy asked after one year--
they asked the European Union,
would you help us fund this?
Nope.
So [INAUDIBLE] said let's
put Triton in its place.
Let's take the Mare Nostrom
and let's put Triton.
The ships look pretty
much the same, right?
They are just military assets.
There's a Navy.
There's a Coast Guard.
But they have a fundamentally
different mission.
Mare Nostrom is deployed
close to the African coast.
That's where people
are drowning.
Trying to retreat 30 miles
from the Italian shore.
Clearly a different purpose.
One was there to rescue
people, the other one
was to protect the border.
And that was made
very, very clear.
Of course, it was
said, OK, if we
come across boats in distress
we will of course rescue people.
We are obliged to do that.
But if you make sure you
are in the wrong place
at the wrong time, you
will not find a boat.
So I'm saying this--
it sounds like I'm
blaming European governments.
But this is a quote from the
Frontex assessment report
when they were
planning the operation.
"It was known the
withdrawal of boats
would result in a higher
number of fatalities."
The decision was
made in spite of.
So that's when we said, OK,
should we rescue people at sea?
It took us probably three
minutes to figure out that.
Yes, of course we should.
Why?
Because it's the
right thing to do.
What do you do when there
are human beings drowning
and you can put a boat and
take them out of the sea?
Do you have really a choice?
Do you have a
justification not to do it?
Of course not.
We didn't ask what was
their legal status.
We didn't ask them are you a
refugee or an economic migrant?
What's your religion?
Are you black or white?
We didn't ask that.
We said let's go into this,
don't ask the question,
but also we were not naive.
Should we?
Yes.
Could we?
We didn't know.
And these were
the questions that
really took us a lot of time.
It's like, OK, we were
used to rescuing refugee--
to assisting refugees around
the world and in Europe.
We had at that time projects
in Italy and in Greece,
small projects for the
people that had arrived.
But what about those
trying to get to Europe?
For us it doesn't matter
their legal stat--
but for states it's
a fundamental thing.
Will they allow us to do it?
Or will we be accused
of the same thing
that Mare Nostrum was accused?
Will the Italians work with us?
Will they allow us to work
with their rescue coordination
center or any rescue city
and disembark people in Italy
as they have been doing it?
Could we do it?
We knew that in the
early 2000s there
were fisherman, commercial
vessels, and one small NGO that
had been prosecuted in
Italy for doing this.
Why?
Because they had
come across a boat.
The boat was sinking.
They had taken people on board.
They had sailed back to Sicily.
And they were either stuck
outside the port saying,
no, you are not
allowed to enter port
because you have people without
the right papers on board.
Or they were allowed to
dock, and they were then
taken to court and prosecuted
for aiding illegal immigration.
So we're like are we going
to be prosecuted as well.
Will they dare to prosecute us?
Can we actually do this or not?
We were marginally
worried about that.
We were more worried
about what will
be the reaction of
those two Europes?
And when say those two
Europes we mean politicians,
we mean public opinion.
We mean the people who actually
give money to MSF in Europe.
Right?
I mean we would face a
stampede of calls saying,
sorry, I don't want to
donate money to MSF anymore.
We had when we did for another
way that happened for a period.
So our fundraising department
were not very happy
that we actually went with the
decision to go with a boat.
But luckily we don't--
the fundraising
departments in MSF
don't make decisions
about operations.
So that was out of the way.
But we had all
these trepidations.
Luckily, the Italians,
much to our surprise,
they said, OK, we will
cooperate with you.
In the end the Coast Guard and
the Navy, they are sea men,
they felt that there was
something to be done there.
So they said, yes.
The reactions of the
rest we couldn't predict.
We thought it was
going to be bad.
We never knew it was
going to be this bad.
So we said, OK, if we're going
to walk into a minefield,
let's be prepared for it.
Let's not give the
others the opportunity
to explain and
manipulate what we do.
Let's explain it ourselves.
Let's explain ourselves.
Let's be clear.
And let's have a very clear
argument of what we're doing.
And we started to tread
very, very carefully.
We are Doctors Without
Borders, but we
didn't go for criticizing the
existence of border controls.
We said what we
are objecting to is
the human cost of those
border controls happening
in the Mediterranean.
It's a difficult line to tread.
We didn't say go
open the borders.
We said these
people are drowning
because they don't have any safe
or legal alternatives to get
to Europe.
You have to change
that if you want
to stop people from drowning.
And of course, if you have the
resources, you have to rescue.
We shouldn't be doing
this job ourselves.
How to convey this message?
You do have to take
journalists on board.
Well, we had if we
wanted this to be known.
But we knew that
we were never going
to be able to
control the message,
to control how this was
going to be reported.
We have our own guidelines
in terms of we're
not going to show certain
kinds of pictures.
We're not going to exploit
people's suffering.
We're not going to--
we're going to let people who
want to talk the opportunity
to talk and give
their testimony,
but we're not going
to force anyone.
We're going to protect
people's privacy.
But how much can
you do that when
you have camera crews on board?
We weighed the two things and
said, we have to just do it.
This needs a bit of
visibility if it's
going to have any effect on
putting pressure for change.
So here we go.
We launched that
boat on April 2015.
From then on the situation went
literally out of our hands.
We tried to be clear
in what we-- these are
some of the snippets.
I'm going to go through this
quickly because you don't want
to read MSF press releases.
But basically [LAUGHS]
what we said is, look,
we're doing this because
people are drowning.
It's the right thing to do.
And we also are going to be
critical of European policy
towards refugees
and asylum seekers.
So we made that clear.
We had to give context to it.
We couldn't do the
NGO trick of saying
there are people drowning,
give me money, I'll save them.
We didn't want that role.
We wanted to say, look,
we want context in this.
This needs to be explained.
The photo without the caption,
it's not going to do it.
This needs context.
This needs an explanation.
And we need to do
justice to what's
happening in the Mediterranean.
So we went with that.
Two days after we
launched the operation
and completely unrelated
to it, this happens.
They are 12,000 lives lost in
two incidents in the same week
because the oil tankers
that were in the area.
They tried to rescue.
They are big boats, small boats.
They are 1,200 people
dead in a single week.
Of course the media
went all over it,
and the situation by then
already it was bigger than us.
Much bigger than us, than
our little boat in the Med.
So how to navigate this?
There was massive
public controversy
and what the EU
does, they come, they
start pointing
fingers at each other.
They say, OK, let's launch an
operation to fight smuggling.
There was nothing about rescues.
We have to fight those
smugglers that bring
the people into the country.
By May, June we said,
OK nobody is jumping in.
We're going to put two more
boats in the operation.
We scaled up.
We had three boats at that
point in the Mediterranean.
And this fourth
thing that we never
expected in different
countries in European society,
in Germany, in France, in
Spain, groups of citizens
started organizing and
copying our model of rescue
and trying to charter boats to
put boats in the Mediterranean
to go and rescue people.
So we had in a year there
were 10 NGO-run boats
in the Mediterranean.
We never anticipated
this result.
We talked about controlling
the message of the narrative.
There was a cacophony of voices
in the Med talking about this.
There were journalists
on all boats.
And it seemed the positive
side of it, it was like,
well it seems that
it's appealing
to some part of Europe
that actually feels--
citizens feel that they have
to do something about that.
So here you go.
I'm going to show you a
three-minute video to give you
a flavor of what the media--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In the past three years,
more than 10,000 men, women,
and children have died trying
to cross this stretch of water.
[YELLING AND SCREAMING]
Migrants.
People.
Each one had a story,
a hope, a dream.
Over just six days, we'll
witness the intensity
of the rescue attempts.
The helplessness
of the migrants,
and the hopelessness of the
effort to end the crisis.
- Keep breathing!
Come on!
- This is what death
and survival looks like.
[END PLAYBACK]
- I just had to cut it
there because it gets worse.
But anyway, it conveys
a reality at sea.
It uses language that
you can question.
It uses-- But that's
what the media--
that's how it started
to look in the media.
The hopelessness
of the migrants,
and the helplessness of the--
The other way.
The helplessness of the
migrants and the hopelessness
of the effort to end the crisis.
What crisis?
Let's see.
So Med.
What do I have here?
Yes, this is really important.
The eastern border.
This is what's happening in the
center of the Mediterranean.
Libya, eastern border.
Three, four months later, you
had a raging conflict in Syria.
You had the extension of
the conflict into Iraq.
You had war in
Afghanistan for years.
You had the announcement
or the sense
that Europe is going to
start closing the borders.
You have people starting to
move through Turkey into Europe.
So these images
on the European--
or call it Eastern Front.
I don't like the language.
I mean this military
language to use now
when we talk about migration.
The Eastern Front makes
me very suspicious.
But this is what Europe's
Eastern Front look like.
There are images of people with
headscarves behind barbed wire
fences.
The misery of those camps in
Greece next to beach resorts,
the soldiers at the fence,
the people behind it.
It really became quite--
the pressure on European
governments was really, really,
really high.
So that's when the
migration crises
became the term to define this.
And that's when the
migration crisis took over.
There was a crisis
at the borders.
And this is some of the images.
I'm going to just go behind.
So that quickly became
the central issue
for the upcoming elections for
several European countries.
That was the main concern
by politicians from all ends
of the political spectrum.
Migration became the weapon
in which those elections
were going to be fought.
It was a problem.
The deaths and suffering you
see had a political cost.
But the arrival of
migrants in Europe
also had a political
cost, and they
were right wing
anti-immigration parties
really pressing their agenda,
and making electoral gains
with it.
So politicians in
power like America
and others, some countries their
response was not coordinated.
Some countries said, at the
beginning, more were coming.
Then they quickly realized
that this was problematic
and they went backwards.
But there was quite an
uncoordinated response,
and this grew in the background.
So there was really an
urgency to end the crisis.
But what crisis are
we talking about?
Whose crisis?
What is the problem that
we're trying to solve?
And that's when September,
just a couple of months
later, the boy on the beach.
I don't even need to show it.
But you know what
that is, right?
That became cover in
newspapers around the world.
That became the poster
child of the crisis.
It became exploited by everyone.
Everyone.
So this was painful.
This was heartbreaking.
This pulled everyone's
heartstrings.
No matter what you thought
about migration, about migrants,
this was a child.
This could have been your child.
This could have been our child
people thought in Europe.
It became the crisis
human-- the crisis became
human, visible, immediate.
It appealed to
something that was not
a theory, that was not numbers.
It was something else.
There was really
true feeling there
for a period, an
outpour of compassion.
That photo came with a caption.
Alan had come with
his mom and his dad
and his little brother
from Aleppo, Syria.
Not from Aleppo, sorry,
from Kobani, Syria.
And that's how Kobani looked
by the time that they had fled.
So we all understood.
The plight of Syrian
refugees was validated.
Right?
If I lived in Kobani,
I would have also left.
I would have also
got on that boat.
I would also pay
$5,000 to a smuggler
to put me on a flimsy boat
and try to get to Europe.
We knew that Alan had died.
We also knew that his
entire family had died
and the father was
the only survivor.
But there's an outpouring
of grief and compassion.
But what to do with it?
What to do with those feelings?
Yes, a lot social
media around it.
A lot of demonstrations.
A lot of clicks.
The world refugee and migrants
went crazy on Twitter.
People took an interest.
But what else do with it?
And this is what I cannot resist
quoting a bit of Susan Sontag.
She has a wonderful book on
regarding the pain of others.
And I'm going to read you
that quote of compassion
that I really like.
"Compassion, " she says,
"is an unstable emotion.
It needs to be translated
into action or it withers.
The question of what to
do with the feelings that
have been aroused, the knowledge
that has been communicated.
If one feels there's nothing
we can do, but who is that we?
And nothing they can do
either and who are they?
Then one starts to get
bored, cynical, apathetic."
That was what we
were discussing.
Where is this going to go?
It was short lived.
Two months later, you get that.
You get a brutal
terrorist attack in Paris.
You've got 130 people dead.
You get the media
all over it again.
You get ISIS
claiming the attack.
And you get a French
prime minister
that very quickly says
the terrorist threat has
slipped in across the border.
They have taken advantage of
the migration crisis to slip in.
The threat has
come from outside.
That, by the way,
wasn't even true.
And the police investigation
would reveal something else.
It was not even--
But who cares?
Once it has been said,
how do you unsay it?
Right?
So where do we go now?
Oh, yeah, let me show you
a bit about these guys.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Every week, every
day, every hour ships
packed with illegal
immigrants are
flooding the European border.
An invasion is taking place.
- This mass
immigration is changing
the face of our continent.
We're losing our
safety, our way of life,
and we will become a
minority in our own country.
Our future is under attack.
- It all starts right here
at the European borders.
- Right here the illegals
make the first step
on European ground.
Right here the NGOs
and human traffickers
are endangering the
future of our people.
Right here our governments
are betraying and failing us
by letting this happen.
- From all across Europe,
we gather here in Sicily
to take action.
Our mission is clear and
simple, to defend Europe.
- We want to expose the
so-called humanitarian NGOs.
They cooperate with
human traffickers
who live from people's misery.
We want to protect our borders
and face those criminals
on the sea.
- This is just the beginning.
We are preparing a
big rescue mission
on the Mediterranean Sea.
- It's a mission
to rescue Europe
by stopping illegal immigration.
We want to get a
crew, equip a boat,
and set sails to
the Mediterranean
to chase down these
enemies of Europe.
To start our mission,
we need your help.
The immigration lobby is funded
with hundreds of thousands
of euros from the government
and from big donators.
We on the other hand depend
only on you to fund this mission
and to defend Europe.
- Where the governments,
fail we step in.
Because this land is ours.
It starts here, and
it has to end here.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
- The plot thickens, right?
The plot becomes ever
more interesting.
We also didn't anticipate this.
We didn't anticipate that it
was going to be another boat
to rescue Europe.
These people, by the
way, in the video,
they are there
with a small boat,
with megaphones and launching
flares against our boat.
That's our boat,
the Catania post.
They did this action against
an MSF boat very quickly.
We decided just not to
give them the airtime.
So we didn't really
denounce it or anything.
So that was still there.
Who wants to know
how this ended?
I mean it's--
It was short lived too.
Here you go.
So these guys
crowdfund 50,000 pounds
to put a boat in the Med.
They managed to get it.
They chartered a boat called
the C-Star in Djibouti.
And they start sailing
towards Europe,
towards the Mediterranean,
trying to stop the NGOs.
And the irony is of it they
touched land in Cyprus--
[LAUGHTER]
They landed in Cyprus, and
five of their crew members
who had been recruited--
they were from Sri Lanka,
they applied for
asylum in Europe.
So the police gets
on board of the boat,
and they say, what
are you doing?
And they find that the rest
of the crew, another other 25
guys, are also from Sri Lanka,
and they don't have any papers.
So they're taken to court, and
they are deported from Cyprus
for people smuggling.
[LAUGHTER]
Then they go to Italy.
In Catania, they face
a canoe demonstration
by just a bunch of Italians
that get on [INAUDIBLE]..
They get on the sea and they--
then they try to get to Tunis.
And there are Tunisian
fisherman saying
we don't like this racist boat.
We don't want it to land here.
And to add insult to injury,
I think the best part of this,
they get an engine
break down, and they
had to be rescued
by one of the NGOs
they were trying to bring down.
[LAUGHTER]
It's funny.
We laughed a lot at the time
when Defend Europe went down.
There was social media.
We had a bit of a
laugh with these guys.
But what they were saying
really condensed some discourse
that was really installing
itself in the narrative.
They were not alone.
These are young
people around Europe.
They are not that important.
But what they say
echoes with many people.
So they had to do something.
Imagine yourself, you're
a European prime minister.
You have the MSF
of the world saying
you have to rescue people.
You have to open safe
and legal alternatives.
And you have these other people
saying stop the invasion.
So what do you do?
You cannot agree
within yourselves.
When people arrive--
Italy's saying we
need to be helped.
The other countries need to
be taking immigrants as well,
and we need to distribute.
The other countries all want
to look in the other direction.
The Italians say why us?
Greece the same.
So what do you do?
You cannot fix that.
You have Greek camps that
really look appalling.
Some of the worst
camps I ever seen.
You have people at the fences.
You have all the coverage.
So what do you do?
You pass the buck.
The magic bullet.
That was the first group
photo of European politicians
throughout the crisis.
There were going to be two.
That was a first one.
The first time they actually
managed to agree and announce
something.
And the announcement
was that they
have got Turkey to agree on
taking the refugees back.
How much would it
cost for Turkey
to agree to take
the refugees that
have crossed to Greece
and to Eastern Europe
back into Turkey,
control their border,
and prevent further
departure of boats?
What do we need to give them?
It was easy.
It was $6 billion
euros over three years.
And the problem is that the
Turkish citizens will have easy
access to Europe through a
quicker system getting visas
or a visa-free--
And once all this was
sorted, maybe there
was going to be
a orderly program
to resettle some of the Syrian
refugees that had arrived back
into Europe once they determine
how that was going to--
Very few of those things
actually remained fulfilled.
But that was what can
we do if we don't agree,
and we don't want the people?
We just pass it back
to something else.
Just push it out.
By the way, that moment is
when we knew we were losing.
We knew we had no traction.
But that moment we knew
that there was no hope.
We were meeting with
all those people.
We had access to those people.
We had a powerful campaign going
on with other organizations.
We had media coverage,
everything we wanted with it.
But we were getting no traction.
The solution was not going
to come by rescuing people
or providing better conditions.
Europe, no.
The solution was to
pass the buck outside.
So at that moment we knew.
This is lost, and
search and rescue
is on the way to being
terminated as well.
Why?
Because if you want people
to really remain in Libya,
you cannot have NGOs rescuing
people and bringing them
to Italy.
There's no way
you can have that.
So we knew we were an obstacle.
What we said is keep going.
There are two things we can go.
We're not going to
stop voluntarily.
Just keep going and let's
see if they stop us.
And let's expand our
operations into Libya.
And why Libya?
I'm going to tell you
this very quickly.
We had been talking
to the people
we have rescued for
two years by then.
And they were telling us about
horrible conditions in Libya.
People were arbitrarily
retained, extorted for money.
There were stories
about sexual violence.
about torture.
There were stories about
overcrowded prisons.
There were stories about the
appalling living conditions,
no proper water, no
food, no sanitation.
So we had been discussing
this for a long time.
Can we actually do
something about that?
And the same with sea, it
was like how do we do that?
There was no witnesses.
Jordans didn't get visas
to enter into Libya.
Only a few people had
managed to sneak in by then.
And we said, OK, [INAUDIBLE]
are also not going there.
Can we actually negotiate
access so they are involved.
Let's negotiate with
the Libyan people
managing detention centers.
Can we work there?
Why would they
allow us to do that?
So could we convince them that
we can go and serve a purpose?
Let's agree to be used to
improve detention conditions.
Because we could do something
for the people of Libya.
We could actually improve
food, improve water,
improve sanitation.
But at the same
time, we're not going
to do it at the
price of not showing
what's going on in there.
So we wanted to really use
that presence to bear witness
with what was going on.
And can we keep our team safe?
When we are at
sea, you're at sea.
But if in Libya, you get
kidnapped in two minutes.
You get a death
threat, and you're out.
You get one staff
killed and you're out.
So that was a bit
of a trade off.
Can we actually do this safely?
We decided to go with it and
with accepting that challenge.
How do you actually
operate there
without being co-opted into
a white-washing exercise?
Now you are there.
Yes, you can feed
people properly.
You can give them proper
water, and say there's
your medical care.
What are you going to
do when they bring you
the same person twice
with wounds that
are consistent with torture?
Are you going to say something?
Or are you just going
to put a patch again?
So we started this very
difficult relationship
with the legal authorities,
but they allowed us to be in.
And it was very,
very, very tense
and very difficult to
manage that operation.
So we launched
this in June 2016.
Just a few months
later or a year later,
the second group shot came
from the European leaders.
They had managed to find a
deal again to pass the buck.
Let's work with the Libyans
to make sure that people
don't depart from the shores.
And Libya was much more
difficult than Turkey.
You can't talk to
Erdogan in Turkey.
Erdogan sort of controls
Turkey pretty well.
In Libya, there are
different factions.
It was much more
difficult to control that.
And they had to--
how are you going to really
prevent people from going?
And what they said at that
point was this mixed discourse.
Let me read it
because I get confused
when I read these things.
"With hundreds already
having lost their lives,
the EU is determined to
take additional measures
to reduce migratory flows."
So the notion is like let's make
sure that more lives are not
lost at sea.
Let's keep them there.
If they don't get on
boats, they don't drown.
Right?
Pretty simple.
Whose crisis are
we trying to solve?
So Europe under threats.
That media-- that was the
total of the reporting by them.
And who are those guys in there?
That's the EU funding and
training the Libyan Coast Guard
to intercept and return.
So search and rescue came.
The plan was let's
get rid of the NGOs.
Hand it over to the
Libyans to make sure
that they search, they rescue.
You see the caption there?
They are rescued
to be brought back.
So it's an interception
and return operation.
We knew our boats at sea
had very little time to go.
We decided to, OK,
let's go all out.
We had a report, let's go all
out accusing the EU of funding
torture in Libya.
We did everything we could.
I mean this is just one example.
And we, of course, tried
to facilitate media
reporting as much as we could.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- At this detention
center in Surman,
an eerie silence prevails.
Most of the 250 young
women here tried
to cross the Mediterranean
to reach Europe,
but they didn't make it.
Cynthia from Nigeria
was in a boat that
was stopped by security forces.
They brought her to this camp.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- She says they
were caught at sea,
and their boat
came under gunfire,
and that it's God's
will that she survived.
Cynthia was heavily
pregnant at the time.
Today, she has to use the
detention center toilet
to change her baby's diapers.
And she doesn't know if
the child will survive.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- She says she can't nurse
her daughter because she's
been unable to produce any milk
since her daughter's birth.
German diplomats have
compared the conditions
in many Libyan detention centers
to Nazi concentration camps.
They've just gone public
with their report which
says the young women are often
beaten and raped by the staff.
- There is no phone here.
Since five months, I have not
spoken to my parents, nobody.
We are just here.
- What we are begging them for
[INAUDIBLE] That is all we need
here.
- The managing
staff in some camps
are even accused of
human trafficking.
The camp director in
Surman disputes this.
He accuses western countries
of ignoring the horror.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- Reporters show the problems
and the poor conditions here,
but no one is stepping
up to help us.
We're not getting any support.
- [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
- The staff says medical
aid is urgently needed
at this detention center.
But even if it's
delivered, no one
believes that will make
much of a difference.
[END PLAYBACK]
- That was it.
The game is very clear.
Libya is saying,
just give us money.
We'll detain people properly.
We'll improve conditions.
Today, you have
UNHCR working there.
You have the IOM.
That's how aid is being used
today to just prop this up.
The question for me is
not whether to provide aid
there or not.
The question is at what
price do you provide aid
and how critical
you remain for this?
And how do you
make that balance?
And this is the last slide.
I have two more minutes to go.
Last couple of slides.
So the last step was
very clear to everyone.
Let's get rid of the NGOs.
So it was a quick succession.
There was a smear campaign
very, very quickly.
It's like the
water taxis, it was
installed by Italian
politicians saying,
OK, these water taxis
are bringing the illegals
into Europe.
They are colluding
with smugglers.
You heard what the guys from
Defend Europe were doing.
That really got traction.
There were prosecutions
again to NGOs.
They didn't prosecute us.
But the smaller NGOs that had
been born for a single purpose,
to rescue people
at sea for this,
were really affected by both
the credibility issue of being
cooperating with smugglers.
Their funding went like this,
and some of them disappeared.
The rest had their
boats impounded at sea,
at Italian ports and
in Malta in Italy.
Some of the boats
are still there.
Some people prosecuted.
Nobody has been
condemned for anything.
There's very little evidence.
There's been a massive effort.
There's been intelligence
agents infiltrating
on some of the NGO boats.
Even satellite eavesdropping
interception of calls.
There's been a massive
intelligence effort
to just try to prosecute
the people that
were rescued at sea.
Then intervention from
the Libyan Coast Guard.
The instances of the
Libyan Coast Guard
coming and threatening
NGO boats on the radio,
opening fire on an
MSF boat or other.
[INAUDIBLE] are well-documented.
You can just Google them.
They're all out there.
We all denounced
this as it happened.
The Libyan Coast Guard
got increasingly violent.
And we all got a
letter-- all the NGOs
from their coordination
in Rome, saying, sorry,
we can no longer guarantee
your security at sea.
So the message was clear.
By the summer of 2018,
there was one boat.
From the 10, we went
back to one boat.
And that was our boat.
That was the Aquarius.
The big boat in
the background is
the Aquarius, that orange boat.
That was the last
boat standing by 2018.
That's when Matteo Salvini gets
elected in Italy on this slogan
of stop the invasion.
There's an invasion
taking place.
Italians first.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Italians
first, stop the invasion.
The succession for
this-- and this
is since I was leaving my
job and I came to Radcliffe,
all this happened
over the summer.
You got June 2018,
we had rescued
629 people were not allowed
to dock in Italy anymore.
The ship was adrift
at sea for a week
until we managed to get
an offer from Valencia.
We had to go all
the way to Spain
to be able to disembark people.
In August 2018,
again another rescue.
We were not allowed to disembark
anywhere, not even in Valencia.
In August 2018, we were
sailing under a Gibraltar flag.
Under the UK pressure, that
flag was stripped from the ship.
So the ship was
without registration.
We took three weeks.
We registered again the boat
under the Panamanian flag,
the only country that
would give us a flag.
In September, we did another
rescue, over 58 people
on board.
They told us, you
cannot disembark here.
You have to hand over people
to Libyan Coast Guard.
We said, no way we're
going to do that.
We keep people on board.
We know where people
are going back.
We cannot possibly do that.
So our flag was stripped again.
Italy put pressure on Panama,
and the second flag was--
the ship today
doesn't have a flag.
There's a campaign
running to [INAUDIBLE]..
There is no state that
has been willing to put
a flag on that ship, so the
operation is virtually halted.
The ship is on port.
What Mary had said,
in three years
there were around 425
operations by MSF alone.
77,000 people
assisted in our boats.
Today, there are no search
and rescue boats in the Med.
So far 2000 people have died
in the Med this year alone.
And of course arrivals
in Italy have reduced.
They are probably being
taken back to Libya.
What does this is little
story mean for us?
What does this story
of search and rescue
mean for us in the Med?
What does it say
about the way we
frame this crisis, how
we conceptualize it,
how we think of it?
There are a couple
of questions that I'm
exploring at Radcliffe.
And this is very, very raw.
There's no much
thinking about it.
But these are the questions
that strike me as important.
How do we frame this problem?
How do we talk about this?
How do we talk about them?
We talk about them as
an undifferentiated mass
of people.
We talk about them
as a natural disaster
that is about to strike us,
that it's a threat that we
need to defend ourselves from.
How does this language that
we use to talk about them
allow us to dehumanize
people and strip them
from any attributes
that would actually
question what we are doing?
I couldn't resist
putting this this big
because it's from this morning.
With this crisis, not what
do we talk about them,
what does it say about us?
That's much more
interesting, right?
What does it say about us, how
we're framing the immigration
problem?
When we other people--
when we define the other--
when a group of insiders
decides that the other is
the threat and the enemy.
We know that trick, right?
We saw it throughout history.
We don't need to be
lazy to think oh, what
about Germany 1930s?
We had the Jewish question.
Now we have
immigration question.
We don't need to go to how
Jim Crow's America defined
the Negro problem.
That said, much more
as James Baldwin said,
that said much more about white
America and African-Americans.
What does this say about
how we think about people
and who we are today?
Here in Europe or in Australia.
This guy there is saying
we need a final solution
to the immigration problem--
to the Muslim
immigration problem.
Then these people.
Isn't it much more
dangerous this retreat
into ethnic nationalism,
tribalism, hate?
That kind of speech
makes Sweden great again.
Isn't it much,
much more dangerous
than openness to the world?
How do we define a notion
of us that transcends
barbed wire, border
walls, ghettos,
and has a more egalitarian
and humanist aspiration?
Can we do that?
Shouldn't we try?
What are our values in
these turbulent times?
What are we doing?
Can we afford to be
indifferent and at what price?
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]